[Music]
apology
[Music]
ahoy i'm d-list celebrity dave landau
and you may recognize me from shows such
as louder with crowder comics unleashed
with byron allen and 11 appearances on
margot robbie's doorbell camera where
i'm resisting a rest many people have
seen me on live pd with my pants around
my ankles
fighting cops and being tased
saying i love you margo i love you
well they say hey dave how do you stay
so well groomed i'll tell you how
lawnmower manscape 4.0 it has a safety
shield for my sensitive areas and a
light in case i have to shave in the
woods in the dark what
what
dude
did you use my monkey pox razor it's why
i switched to this
no you're covered in monkey pox you
clearly did finnegan read the label
[Music]
my hair is
[Music]
um
[Music]
right now
[Music]
business
[Music]
dangerous
[Music]
i'm a
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
is that nyquil or just the z-quail that
nyquil yeah good full strength stuff
good it's uh to cheat on my alcoholism
all right
good morning everybody and welcome to
louder with crowder
with dave
happy you could join the show uh today
we are going to be talking about this
week in biden of course we're going to
have a little segment there for you msm
uh calls out crowder oh which is
mainstream media don't start nothing not
microsoft won't be not means but they
did do that too they did yes yes
microsoft bill gates's penis now we have
uh we also have to talk a bit about
woodstock 99 the fbi raid uh or whatever
word they want to call it now because
we're redefining every word imaginable
and uh also lonely single men on the
rise who knew good news and on the rise
is the double entendre all right gerald
a how are you doing today i am doing
well sir it's good to see you in the
chair i know steven's out preparing
we're actually doing a super video and
so he's out doing that today thank you
it's going to be a lot of fun but it's
good to see you sir it's good to see you
i don't i don't ever get to see see you
like i have to look around a monitor to
see your beautiful face make fun of me
yeah people
people don't know we're hidden from each
other well i can see steven steven can
see you but we have contractual
obligations that we cannot see each
other yes it was due to a fight yes
i didn't win
we got token now and how are you doing
today buddy hola there you go it doesn't
make sense
he's like i don't know my culture i
don't know japanese no not a word
case to see hill how are you doing hello
to you my friend
i'm trying to get a good nickname for
him right i've got mace to see pill my
dad used to call me [ __ ] okay well
that would work
from the jerk starting it off like that
well i i i i don't think your dad was
right i think you're a good guy well it
was with love is it was it fade shade
good
o'connor the the
the inner city spelling
already offended half the all right
anyway
uh tim the tool man ahoy how are you
good morning sir good morning to you and
today we have one of my favorite people
in the studio crawdaddy how you doing
i'm great david how are you good thank
you for coming in you're gonna talk
about my new film we are oh okay we got
where the crawdads
coming up later i'm just saying it's a
little foreshadowing we've seen uh we've
seen the trailer maybe on netflix we'll
show it today why not and laying the
brain joining us as well how are you
doing today sir good to be back been uh
been a little bit yes it's been a while
that's why so he was down at the the roe
v wade in washington dealing with the
shenanigans over there many showers many
cleansings after that to get back to
normal so what an awful place lots of
awful people yeah do you get any phone
numbers elaine
i mean we talk after the show
i don't want to kiss and tell in front
of a
he got an interview with that kentucky
swimmer yeah that's right oh yeah
married though he's married yeah oh well
still married what's the
point of marriage nothing
i'm married no that's not true no that's
later in the show it's a it's a tease
for later oh
yeah
well i mean
yeah we can get into that's that riley
gaines she's become quite a cultural
icon
yeah she because she came in second by
tying with uh
i think fourth the howard stern was a
satchel yeah
[Laughter]
she looks like howard anyway well trump
brought her up on on stage at his last
speech oh did he yeah
uh
to congratulate her just to you know
point out the injustice of it all
i didn't see that and he said i could
out swimmer
did he really didn't
she was like ncaa record holder yeah you
can give me four big macs
a couple of diet cokes
hey i'm guessing if she was some busted
swimmer he probably wouldn't have
brought her up though
nice photo op for the man oh for sure
absolutely well let's ask this question
for the question of the day does the
mainstream media have a responsibility
to remain unbiased
[Music]
does it matter i mean yeah but yeah it
doesn't matter tell us what you think
comment but honestly comment below do
they have a responsibility to remain
unbiased
do you feel that they do
i do i don't want to lead the witness
they should
i mean they should right yeah it's it's
just that's what i liked about
journalism like you got a good
detroit remember like mort crim
or bill bonds bonds he was drunk most of
the time all the time yeah yeah most of
the time drunk but an unbiased reporter
my dad tells me a story about bill bonds
doing a up close and personal in a
black stage in a stool spotlight on him
he leaned back
not only fell off the stool off the
stage the day is completely
off camera they had to cut
make sure you broke your toupee in half
that's part of the show people our
anchor disappeared from view that's
beautiful
bill bonds was the best that was a real
news man yeah i miss him the old days
you know i don't i don't know if they
have a responsibility that but they
ought to disclose their bias they should
it's okay let them all be that's fine
know that this guy is coming from this
angle this one's that's what needs to be
laid out there i think that's a fair
point you have tucker coming from a very
certain perspective who knows my buddy
jimmy fallon who's on fox radio for
example he's coming from a certain
perspective
uh cnn they pretend they're not for some
reason but we know
yeah anyway
they always were they they always have
been we thought walter cronkite was
unbiased but now no well we thought
brian williams was in a helicopter
who knew
he was just a hero you can also join
steven and i uh we're going to be on
tour with the rebel with the cause tour
we're going to be in phoenix september
16th that's arizona houston september
17th and charleston west virginia
october 8th um also you can catch me
sweet sweet buttery dave september 30th
in lexington michigan at the lexington
theater and october 1st in bay city
michigan yeah at the state theater uh
with my boy derrick richards he and i
are putting on a little show there well
shindig yeah mostly dancing river dance
i don't i don't doubt that actually no i
do a lot of river dance yeah i think you
can tell by my physique that i'm a
dancer
a quick feat yeah very very quick people
the shows you and steven are doing are
monsters looking at the the ticket sales
are massive i click on tickets and it's
like an arena and like almost sold out
and i'm like this is a weird me yeah
well we scaled it for basketball we're
opening up to hockey and now we're here
and then when it's women's basketball
everything it's just the court yeah i
think we passed the wnba's ticket sales
on day one so i wouldn't mind going to
it for the season it's a wnba game you
know
easy
bathroom accessibility the energy the
energy is going to be incredible
parking is free the dozens of fans are
quite passionate oh yeah
one of them's got a vape pen and is
getting tackled
[Laughter]
are we trading that woman for like a
seri like a hitman oh yeah yeah an
international arms dealer
the lord of war do you remember that
movie yeah that's basically who we're
trading this person for he was like the
taliban's main supplier of weapons yeah
he killed a lot of americans last name
is boot or something like i think we
absolutely need to get our citizen back
i'm going to go ahead and say that right
right that's how it's a big bargain
maybe for like some tito's vodka or
something yeah something more you know
even if i was okay or something yeah if
i was over there i'd be like look guys i
don't gotta go that high
no we need her back isn't she the only
female on earth to have ever stuffed to
basketball
i don't know
i think so is she she might be candace
parker she's able to no there's she
could candace parker won the dunk
contest because she just dunked she was
able to actually she was able to
yes
my buddy eric ball was oh my gosh my
buddy eric's sister is a coach i'm
trying to think of what school but yeah
she can dunk really oh yeah she's from
detroit great great well
uh yeah i should why point it out but
yeah she's a
hell of a basketball player though but i
think she's the only one that's dunked
without actually jumping oh
[Laughter]
it's like me on a fisher-price room
little tykes doesn't count no i don't
jump when i do tiptoe
you keep swatting your son though that's
weird yeah i only play children my son
can beat me
i taught him how to play horse and i'm
like all right you win again
daddy's got
the older you get the more you realize
that the athletics came from my father
and my brother and i should have been a
girl
you still can be dave there's still time
well very forgiving time i'll get a
netflix special
so
uh anyway let's talk about this uh a
little bit uh i don't know if you saw
this you guys don't know if you are
believers
but
at his finland concert yesterday justin
bieber decided uh to employ some
questionable dance moves
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is normal in finland i'm sorry what
is that is he high
i
i mean probably
oh it keeps going
in case you were wondering that's a lot
of goose stepping
i'm surprised he can uh walk after
crashing his car into that house in l.a
oh wait that was ann hey they shouldn't
have put the house in the road no
[Laughter]
he's got some talent though i'm gonna
admit it very talented i really like
because he came up as a kid and i never
really got it i was way past it and then
i saw him do some acoustic stuff and i
was like this dude's talented he does
have some talent and then i saw him
goose stuff here and i was like this is
this is what you want to do yeah but he
held the mic up that was the that was
the key that made it different oh well
that's true it was his signature move he
probably looked at it it's like looking
at the tour he's like that's a long tour
yeah finland's not getting my best yeah
hitler
tyler just wish he had a wireless
well we're looking for his new album uh
live at auschwitz and uh what can't do
that no him i mean justin he can't no
that's it's closed off for concerts oh i
thought he's doing it still is it
canceled yeah i don't know but gundersen
pointed out to me earlier you know the
song where are you now mm-hmm is that
why
i didn't realize and gundersen pointed
this out to me it's actually about jews
where are you now
no he's looking for him under the
floorboards oh jeez
yeah he was banging on the stage to see
if anybody was under yeah
makes perfect and glorious bastard style
it really is
he just sits there and has a christopher
waltz conversation with the booker
are you hiding anything
all right
well let's uh let's admit the one thing
guys i think we can all agree running a
country can be hard it is yeah but
apparently not half as hard as getting
dressed or shaking hands
that brings us to this week in biden
wait if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump then you
ain't black
yeah
poor bastard
i know right
this is the leader of the free world
he had to ask his wife to help look at
his black there's there's a little bit
of a breeze i get it but every hand
there and knows you turn
into breathe
turn so it blows
towards you
like a weather vein there we go yeah got
it i got first handshake i'm just glad
one of the fat boys is there now our
great speaker our partner who all of
these bills we've made if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or trump and you ain't black i love
it man in his defense when my shoulder's
acting up my wife will help me grab a
sleeve there's nothing wrong with that
it's figure out what was happening to
the suit jacket behind him yeah i also
do that to my son if i have to take him
to a wedding and a funeral or any he's
seven
that's roughly equivalent to help him
with his reading glasses
no unfortunately he doesn't have him yet
he's not a nerd
[Laughter]
that's scary though it's so sad how you
know
much worse he's getting oh speaking of
worse they're putting a child next to
him right now he's signing some
legislation on cnn oh this child is
someone's getting sniffed brave
dangerous i hope not he is definitely in
the blast zone right as she is
in the sniff zone
oh there comes oh oh
oh the pheromone do it don't do it don't
do it oh
she's got a no oh my
god he's alive this is his life she's
got a lot they're trying to cut away now
yeah
that's smell like cabbage
come here
get closer touch my leg
oh you can keep that it's very sweet
because uh the these people they were
the they their father her father died
she is
it's a very sweet moment but biden's
creepy yeah he's very creepy in these
moments is this gonna actually help
veterans this is the burn pit
legislation that he signed that was uh
some helping veterans and some helping
whatever democrats wanted
yeah so more money is going to uh not
veterans yeah than veterans but they're
gonna make it look like they were doing
it for all right it says veterans on the
bill so you know yeah
yeah so it's the it's the false uh it's
at the 4 trillion earmarked to buy you
know ethanol plants and some democratic
districts oh good yeah that's good yeah
well i'll be still waiting for my check
va still same address didn't move yeah
still there send it there you can send
the one that my mom died at
waiting for the check well i don't know
it's funny to me it's because it hurts
all right has the concept of getting rid
of ear marks and pork ever been
discussed i mean it's unbelievable to me
it's just assumed it should that's the
way we work yeah
it's tragic
the average american doesn't realize
this goes on
they think a bill is a bill it's not
it's just a bunch of fluff that bill we
had to look at for the irs related bill
it was 755 pages and steve was like can
you just look through this for a second
like oh yeah that shouldn't be too hard
and then i looked oh 755 pages yeah
there's no way the people in congress
know what they're passing well no that's
why every bill just ends up like that
because they get it and they're like
what yeah i don't yes somebody look at
the notes for this can we get a five
page bill and i'm gonna be judged based
on the title yep and what i did with it
and then a paralegals like yeah i read
it
and they're like that's cool you have
painted nails sir
i had it
but they know the people in the the
media are just going to run cover for
them
yeah of course and i you know and again
i i we talked about that with jon
stewart i think his heart was in the
right place and i think uh it was good
that he had uh apologized to the
republican
and
i think people who
have any sort of compassion want the
right thing yeah
i just don't think there's a lot of
people in politics that have that sort
of compassion no
no but the real a-holes are the ones
that play on that compassion to try to
get their own agenda passed absolutely
that's the best way to do it is tug on
the heartstrings of people that actually
care
sad
it's like an abusive parent like using
their child to
manipulating their child to get what
they want in a marriage or something
like that yeah all bills are essentially
uh who's that schedule
the the gross girl
are you talking about how dare you that
one no the the uh the swedish girl no
the tlc
i shouldn't say jokes till i know him
but it was a good one though but i bet
it was the fastest man on his feet
[Laughter]
i can't do it
whatever rudy
fair
so uh let's talk about something more
serious for real uh if you can
long pause
msnbc
msm
because msnbc also did this so that's
the reason why i'm jumping ahead on it
msm calls out crowder last night
uh it was msnbc had a panic attack over
stevens using the phrase this is war
the comments about war aren't limited to
anonymous users right-wing youtube
influencer stephen crowder wrote
tomorrow is war on his public twitter
account the other thing you write about
you gotta sleep well
in these crazy far-right forums moving
into the mainstream you say more
mainstream pro-trump influencers
including podcasters the millions of
followers on youtube or twitter have
also heightened their rhetoric tomorrow
is war stephen crowder who has over 5
million subscribers on youtube and one
million followers on twitter said in a
tweet quote sleep well um i don't think
you got it
right they broke it up like it's two
tweets
how much i mean that's another whole
problem right the mainstreaming of this
and there's the fact that so much of it
seems whether it's donald trump himself
or people uh who are ally with donald
trump they seem to be doing this
intentionally they're stirring these
people up um
do you talk about all that
yeah i mean these steven crowders of the
world are not going to be on the front
line of the civil war right the one
thing that you keep hearing is
uh that they have crossed the rubicon
that you know there's this is basically
past the point from our show then that
they are in a full-fledged war now
that's the big thing that you're
carrying this morning and if you're
hearing this by the way from people like
stephen crowder who has what six million
uh youtube subscribers on like very
civilian platforms uh can you imagine
how bad it is in uh these telegram
spaces uh i can tell you right now it's
worse than you'd imagine
why is it bad one you're not in front of
the white house
just saying if you want to be authentic
and also it was honey boo boo i was
thinking of oh
there you go see what i mean because the
mom
well let me let abuses
just scatty let me just say this have
they lost the ability to understand that
sometimes when you when you say
something like that you're not calling
people to violence we'll get to this
like we've very clearly said we're not
calling people to violence there are
other ways to fight ideologies when you
talk about going to war politically
against an opponent
this is moronic this is taking something
completely out of context and saying oh
this is definitely what they meant they
want people to go and be violent and
then i love how he included sleep well
but he read it as a threat
like what the boogeyman says
what stephen essentially meant is more
and more is happening to you where more
and more government agencies are coming
after you so sleep well it was a bit of
a tone of sarcasm yeah it had nothing to
do with a threat whatsoever no and
tomorrow is war tomorrow we're fighting
this
we're just like we're on a show that
combats that
i didn't even continue on sentence he
combats that he was he was very clear
about that oh very good i mean there has
been much harder many times sure
absolutely not literally that little
reward i mean he was very clear on it he
says it and we'll get to it it's like
four times explicitly they're hacked
they they know what they're doing they
know what nuance is
i if you're believing it at this point
it's beyond your beyond saving because
if you can't see what tactics they're
using to smear very
normal very
cordial political discourse then then i
don't know where we go from here because
it's so blaringly obvious what they're
doing glaringly obvious blaringly
obvious blatantly i don't know they're
idiots that's all i know you mixed
clearly
yep it's obvious well it is obvious and
it's if they want to act like they're
intelligent then you can't really
pretend that you don't know the language
you can't really pretend you aren't
aware of what's actually being said
because then you have to be held as
everything that you've said is
accountable exactly i could say the same
thing to them like oh they're going to
war against us they're they're saying
that this is war and that they're
preparing for this and
it doesn't make any sense like i'm not
going to think that these guys
especially those guys on msnbc are going
to any kind of war another fighting for
their right viewpoint i understand
sarah palin said we need to target these
controversies
districts
she's thinking about target
assassinating yeah what exactly it was
after gabby gifford had been shot and so
they tried to fold that into it it's
unbelievable
well it's whatever they'll do to push
this agenda across and we frankly we
don't care we don't care anymore it
doesn't it doesn't offend us we don't i
mean i'm not bothered by no stephen
isn't yeah they're just upset that
someone's watching another show and not
theirs well yeah did you see how
conveniently how conveniently quick we
became mainstream yeah like when did
that happen right right i mean of course
we do mainstream numbers but we've
always been fringe until oh all of a
sudden we need you as the example so
you're mainstream today right yeah and
these these god you're mainstream when
you're a threat that's the only time you
become mainstream what term did he use
gerald he called a civilian yes a
civilian platform yeah oh i see yeah not
the back channels at the pentagon
it's not the ms nbc platform yes where
they've invested in the vaccines we
don't reach dozens of thousands of
followers dave are you trained in the
funny
have you been to clown college
yes i am and journalism school
well yeah that's
it is that same thing though even as a
comic where it's like if you take that
very seriously
uh i'm a comic
yeah
you're wrong
what this whole thing puts to bed is
both sides ism right it doesn't exist
it's a stupid argument because how many
times have you heard steven tell people
go watch msnbc go watch cnn i want you
to watch this and then watch us yeah
read salon yes go and check out the hill
how many times
and i'll tell you zero they would never
want any of their audience to actually
watch this show because the narrative
will be gone like that that's right yeah
oh absolutely the only thing we keep on
is cnn yes yeah and we actually pulled
up what tweets uh on twitter we look at
and mine was 50 50 on each side i'm
aware of both news i'm more of both
platforms yeah it's also because i don't
necessarily side with anything fully we
source from them yeah of course well my
question to you guys is like what is the
proper response so this is the the
framing right now and i know we're gonna
get to a washington post article here in
just a second comment guys what is the
proper response comment about gerald's
face
don't please not that
something happens that's never happened
before in history you find out
information about this that they already
knew what documents were there they were
there talking to their lawyers there's a
conversation that typically happens in
these
instances where lawyers say hey we want
these documents to be brought back to
the national archives which seems to be
at the very center of all of us for some
reason they finally are relevant for
some reason
what is the proper response
if you do something that has never been
done before in the history of our
country what would you like me to do
because what i see right now is an fbi
run amok and we've seen it over and over
and over and they typically have either
a group of people that they target but
they have one target that seems to be at
the top of their list for the last six
seven years and you do something else to
inflame people what did you expect would
happen well it's my understanding that
one of the bicyclists in the fbi just
wanted their padlock back
well they had to get it from somewhere
that's a fair point
so let's be fair these people have
unwittingly created the cleanest
presidency ever he's been under such
scrutiny yeah biden has been in the
business for 50 years with no scrutiny
yeah this sword is coming it's coming
his way no violence but if you live
don't say sword darren guess what pretty
november's coming
and can he handle the white light of
that scrutiny i don't think so oh 50
years now trump was in office for four
and they scrutinized him up one side and
down the other the only white light he
sees he tries to walk away from every
day
go to the light no no no no i can't i
can't yet there's something to be said
about waiting and seeing okay maybe
there's some bomb maybe maybe i don't
think so because there never has been
that's possible right it's possible but
so you know him peeing on russian
hookers was possible i guess and that
didn't happen obviously hey look we've
all done stuff i'm j
but if it comes out
that the only reason they were down
there is so they could film national
treasure three and look through the
national archives
there is gonna be a
storm coming and i don't
non-violently of course i know we have
to caveat everything we've called that
whatever red wave the part i just don't
understand is being so brainwashed
regardless of what side you're on that
it shouldn't concern you and yeah it's
not even it's it's said that it should
even take to this point to realize how
bad we've been screwed you should have
realized this before this even happened
but the fact that this hasn't it shines
such a bright light on everything that
i'm surprised how people are still
defending it and defending it but it's
the same thing as you have all these
videos of hunter you have all this proof
of money going to him and money going up
to his dad people go that's a lie it's a
complete lie why it's there like you're
just you're being difficult for no
reason well they just want you to go
quietly as they change everything like
we're going to do that's not even the
mainstream that's just that's just this
elite group
telling people what to think and they're
still pushing that narrative even though
they're being screwed by it they've
gotten away with it for long enough they
think they can do it they tell you they
tell you a lie and then anybody who
tries to oppose the lie
is the problem and they can do it enemy
and that's what i've been saying this
entire time and and you wonder why like
so in this this washington post article
again we're going to get to that right
after this in a quote but this isn't in
there excited this lady said that as the
right
says that these institutions that were
set up for us to peacefully
resolve differences right so the
institutions of government that we've
set up to be able to peacefully resolve
our differences as the right erodes
trust in those institutions and i'm like
do you do you have any self-awareness at
all we're not eroding trust in those
institutions we're literally just
calling balls and strikes and saying hey
they're doing something wrong we didn't
make them do something wrong we didn't
make up something wrong that they did we
pointed out what they did that was wrong
that's it if you have a problem with the
institutions not people not having faith
in them that's the institution's fault
not the people pointing it out
absolutely and that's the point that she
makes in her article that was kind of
the overarching point is we're the
problem because we're eroding trust in
these institutions and of course that's
going to lead to violence and why
wouldn't you erode trust in the
institutions you mean the ones that are
untrustworthy you're right
that's the whole point to this i don't
understand this like i have no i have no
concept of reality that makes sense from
their side right now and i would love
for somebody to explain it to me well if
you have let's say this this form of
justice the judicial system i guess you
would say or part of is that's part of
that right we've seen the racism the
classism and everything that sort of
existed in that right yeah so all of a
sudden that doesn't exist it's always
been perfect it still is perfect right
it's always been a problem but then when
you actually prove it it's like no it's
perfect it's great they should be in
that house
why well
yeah well let's talk more about this the
people coming after uh the host of the
show
not me
yet
yeah well no they they came after me
yesterday today is young david i wrote a
deliberately stupid tweet uh about uh
when are they gonna go after a uh height
and a lager or something and they were
like the number of people that attacked
me as if i was sincerely meaning for
that to be funny was astonishing
i'm just like go you shut up whatever
they have dirt on them it's like have
you not seen the endless videos
that he recorded it's crazy i don't even
mind the hooker thing it's just he takes
taxpayers
really it's like you smoke all the crack
you want i just we're paying for it
yeah
not even getting a kickback on it no it
doesn't it's insanity in a washington
post article titled simmering
threat of violence comes to four with
search of trump property that's a long
title that is a i fell asleep halfway
into it
hannah allen wrote
within hours of search of mar-a-lago
a chorus of republican lawmakers
conservative talk show hosts
anti-government provocateurs and
pro-trump conspiracy theorists began
issuing explicit or thinly veiled calls
for violence those are two different
things
yes very different
she then added today is war
that is all you get on today's show
right wing podcaster stephen crowder
announced tuesday to his nearly 2
million followers on twitter
referring to the program that goes to
his youtube audience of 5.6 million i
appreciate that you finally recognize
that we have some popularity yeah i do
appreciate the number count yeah i don't
appreciate your writing no no no no
writing terrible that uh steven's
defense he did say war just on the show
yeah he did it for that hour and a half
only he did he did
he did it was on a limited basis he said
gore several times he was talking about
the band yes with the different
how can they feign shock at the response
that the right is giving or specifically
that this shows you how do they act
surprised by that when if you look at
every single institution every level of
government besides the supreme court it
is explicitly controlled by democrats
and then every time something like that
seems to happen it happens in one
direction and now finally people are
saying something like oh my god i can't
believe it they're they're essentially
turning
government institutions into an
authoritarian wing yeah it's like when
when
xi jinping became the president of china
he went on his anti-corruption campaign
right well that's all that was was to
weed out all the people that were
dissenting against his views and his
ideas that is there if you could explain
what the difference is here i'd love to
hear it yeah well you know what makes
this even more perplexing to me is that
this comes from the generation that was
anti-government this comes from the
generation that spent all of their time
growing up
protesting the government because they
didn't trust the institutions of the
united states of america and now they're
in power and wondering why people
question by the way our system of
government is set up specifically for
this the government is never supposed to
have a free pass to do whatever they
want the citizenry absolutely can
question the government at every single
turn
we go through elections to change it we
don't go through war necessarily to
change that right but we are supposed to
be able to question at every single turn
of course you should fear for your job
if you're in politics if you make a
decision that the people don't like
you should fear that you are going to
get voted out and run out of office
that should be your fear and if you go
even further than that then i understand
that there are processes within the
judicial system to take care of that too
but
what do they expect people to do just
sit there and go oh yeah yeah i don't
like what's going on in the government
right now but i'm just a citizen of this
country i have no responsibility for
what actually happens here i don't have
kids that have to live here in 20 40 50
60 years and that they don't have
potentially kids that are going to have
to live in a country too i don't need to
preserve democracy i know people have
died for it by the thousands by the
hundreds of thousands but yeah no i
can't be bothered to actually you know
pay attention to what's happening
well said
i'm just friends well i mean if we're
supposed to be a people in charge of our
government shouldn't they be afraid of
us instead of now where we're constantly
being afraid of them
because that's what's been laying into
us endlessly now the only power they
have is the power we have given them it
is not theirs it is ours
and they're taking way more than we've
given them yes yes they've taken away
more money than we've given them they've
taken way way way
the even the idea of being a politician
is about serving the public and i
haven't seen many and this goes right or
left that i've seen that do anything for
the public i see nothing but
self-interest damn
speaking of self-interest my favorite
guy is coming up next adam
adam kinzinger oh oh my gosh
i don't know that there's a politician
that's supposed to be on our side that i
dislike
more he cries than adam
[Laughter]
he also sits down to pee i don't know
this for a fact listen sometimes it's
warranted it's wrong oh no i'll do it in
the middle of the night so i don't
loudly wake up everyone or you know in
the morning when things are
you know yeah some of them are relaxed
a rather you know large stream yeah and
you want to make a mess easy gerald
yeah i get it i get it i have rubber
sheets
i also have leather sheets i want my
bathroom to look like csi needs to
investigate come on
what are you doing in your bathroom just
normal stuff because i had a lot of
dongs when i was over there he had a lot
of dongs
he was in vietnam dave to be clear
what's a dong in vietnam it's their
money oh it's just a silly name for
currency
i heard gerald's voice and his lips
weren't moving and yeah it's weird how
that happens
is there is is it a very low value
it really holds a lot of songs to make
things happen
yeah
another one
oh man you can't believe it i mean
so many dongs when i was in vietnam
just slinging them left and right man
everywhere you go i was just like dongs
you want a dong here you need go ahead
okay he's just cracking up here because
you have so many yeah he's just cutting
these i know sometimes i do it to myself
well i i enjoy the fact that we have i
love dongs or whatever you just said now
i just said i didn't say that at all
[Laughter]
look i don't mind a dong
i just wanted to be worth something
that's all look i've i have many dongs
that i hope to one day be valuable there
you go i kept some and brought them home
they're trophies
if you will
from my
my teen gardeners all right so uh let's
uh talk about adam kinzinger speaking of
creeps uh cried about stephen using the
phrase this is war in one of his tweets
we're gonna pull that up sorry i did i
wasn't criticizing so you can just say
this on twitter now that's what he said
yeah adam you can say a lot of stupid
[ __ ] on twitter have you been on twitter
adam or just your intern read mine from
yesterday
you can say [ __ ] death threats and then
you report them and they're like
that's not cause it's you
[Laughter]
you can say the worst stuff imaginable
on twitter because it's a wasteland but
here's the thing
you can say that on twitter because he
wasn't making a threat right that's
probably the most important part of that
tweet
stephen was saying that we're standing
up for something because we think what
happened was wrong
everything that he said to be clear
steven was never calling for violence
if you don't believe me just take a look
at exactly what he said yesterday
this is so wrong
so tyrannical there needs to be a hill
that you're willing to die on
this is it i don't mean literally
i'm not calling you to violence unlike
what's being implied on twitter eric
swalwell with a fight like hell
banging chinese spies
today is a day that we all have the
right
to be pissed off to yell to scream
to behave not as egregiously as the left
it's time to fight fire a little bit
with fire and today we're also going to
get into i was really spending all night
and i didn't sleep much thinking about
what is it that i can do what is that we
can do here or we can offer you
quantifiable steps
that you can take
and some of those are going to have to
be addressed on mud club not on youtube
not because it's a call for violence not
because it's a call for
a physical civil war
but because i don't know the rule book
and i know that they're on high alert
over there at youtube claim to be
carrying our mantle republicans
conservatives
they need to fear you not saying
violence i'm saying they need to fear
you going on a campaign to remove any
and all of the power they so
desperately
desperately desire
that's interesting pretty seems kind of
clear that it in no way was an actual
hmm
well i don't even want to say actual
threat it just wasn't a threat because
people don't have time to watch the show
so they must be fed by the media matters
folks
subscribe to the show and parse that out
to uh msnbc do you have a media matters
moment clip yeah no
i'll do it deeply desire to flick them
off i should have thought about that
earlier just do a little spread eagle
yeah what do you think the chances are
the washington post reporter or the
msnbc hack actually watched the show
no no there's no way how about how about
eleven percent maybe go through you know
i don't know and then if they did it was
eleven percent right yeah exactly maybe
go through the steps of pulling a
transcript of the show you know you can
do that right you know you can do that
and then do a search and make sure you
understand what he actually said it's a
publicly available show well yeah but
yeah nothing you know nothing reads tone
like a transcript
that's the problem is they don't look
into any of this the way that they
should it's just so stupid like when we
pull clips of people saying things we're
very careful to make sure that we take
them in context
yeah because we don't want to get it
wrong we don't want to make it sound
like somebody's saying something that
they're not
right
he does
yeah exactly it's not like when you know
you guys are just having fun you know
messing with me we're actually trying to
do
the right thing and show what people
actually believe and say
and honestly
stephen gets pissed off if we bring
something and it's like no no that's not
the full deal
because it's not what somebody is
actually saying these guys don't care
about that steven's been labeled
and by proxy all of us too right we've
been labeled as right-wing provocateurs
what are we saying that's provocative we
want you to have more freedom we want
the government to have less control over
your life we want there to be more
prosperity we want every class of people
in this country to feel like they can do
it not that you have to have somebody
help you do it all the time we want to
help people that are in need but we
think charity is probably a better way
than stealing money through taxation and
spending it on ukraine and other stuff
that people like by the way the
inflation reduction act where they're
doing a whole bunch of climate stuff in
there that'll definitely reduce
inflation that's all we want i don't
know i think i think it makes sense to
send 90 billion dollars over to the
ukraine yeah and then go after etsy and
ebay accounts and keep printing money
yeah it all works out i mean i just hate
it
this can't fail
they're not all wrong dude please stop
going in my etsy accounts they make
wonderful bracelets
they're for a friendship yeah mm-hmm i'm
sure they are you got one i got one did
you like it two i didn't um you didn't
get one i think it sucks
when they finally realize that they're
the man
i don't know that they're the old geezer
they're the fuddy-duddy they're the
person without a touch they're every
institution as lane said earlier yeah
you've lived long enough to be well the
problem is a lot of people don't realize
that they're that until they're being
thrown into a mass grave and i hate to
be that blunt but it's the truth yeah
and all the fun all the snark all the
edge all the rock and rolls on the right
all of it yeah
they're just they are the man
well it's interesting to even look at
that side of the left because it's this
uh idea of like you should all be
accepting and uh we're all anti-bullying
yet they use all tactics of mob
mentality yeah blindly attacking and
only going after people once it's deemed
safe to destroy someone they're the
completely the part the mainstream media
the left everything at this point it's
just kicking someone when they're down
that's all they do well and one thing
just as a final point on this um
in that article don't you tell me when
there's no no no no no no no no i'm
saying the final thing i'm going to say
about this article right he's got a
paper name on the sign excuse me um
i have beaver teeth
and i have drawn a beaver
how do you have time for that i don't
know on the show while you were talking
i was nothing that i say i was bored in
that two-minute die tribe of nonsense i
love it i'm just glad the uh okay i'm
just glad the balcony is clear today so
i know right getting heckled i know they
were well it's not clear they're just
making out pretty hard
who has the time to listen
no she she made a point and she
referenced something she said of course
the the rhetoric on the right is getting
more violent as evidenced by january 6th
she said that twice
that's the evidence
the thing that they've drummed up the
thing that they have made into the
greatest threat to democracy that's ever
existed in the united states of america
is now being used as evidence that of
course the right
is getting more violent
the greatest threat was that raid at
mar-a-lago far worse than january 6.
yeah well and i saw george sakai um
brilliant uh
tweet something out about how uh the
left and threat violence in 2011 when
hillary got investigated whatever it was
and it's like what what are you talking
about are you talking about when obama
was in our office
do you realize anything that you mean
it's an entirely different time now do
you mean when she got our ambassador
killed in benghazi
yeah and then she bleached an entire
server hiding the proof which by the way
i saw left-wing people they were
protesting everywhere because of it yeah
nobody was on her side at the time
and were they threatening violence
yeah
they have more trout they have more
trouble with some dude on twitter saying
he's gonna i don't know do whatever then
an entire mob killing a ton of
contractors and an ambassador right
that's cool no it's funny that's chill
but
it's uh yeah while her husband takes a
sex plane over to fiji
if you're gonna fly dave
that's true
air epstein oh i noticed casey didn't
hit the allegedly button
yeah
why would you there's no alleged leader
in case a noose falls from the overhead
compartments
secure yours first before
before your child you've just had sex
with oh
jeez
well it's not like it's fake anyway
all right well you know what i can say
to these people honestly uh
there has to be thorough research done
on this show because we are at risk of
always being pulled off
that's why
uh stephen was careful with his words
yesterday and the day before it's why
i'm careful i'm not really that careful
with my words but carefulish ish gerald
is very careful with his words um
i think everybody on here is careful
with her but we do have a sincere
point here and the idea too that uh with
the whole right wing and taking that
over i have been very open about the
fact that i have a left ideology that is
very open i believe in god i believe in
a lot of things and but what is going on
now and on that side has nothing to do
with any principles involving freedom of
speech or anything that i was raised to
believe in or anything that i would have
ever really considered democratic you're
just part of a system that is dividing
this country in half and i encourage you
to stop allowing it that's all i can
really say about it and i think that was
more of steven's point yesterday is open
your eyes and stop blaming everything on
one
guy just because you don't like his
tweets but i miss his tweets i do
mississippi they were freaking hilarious
you know what i miss
hairy balls i'll tell you what i don't
just kidding that's the last thing i
miss
i do not miss them at all
because i don't know if you guys have
heard
it's smooth sack stummer did you know
that i did i actually this is great do
you have a manscape i do it's great
isn't it i love it i love it too
fantastic i like to watch you use it oh
that's weird you don't know i'm there
but you have a tree with uh branches
that
they support my weight not for long
[Laughter]
just me with little binoculars
you don't need them dave you don't need
hey gerald
my god look at that thing i don't know
if that's dame edna or mrs doubtfire
yeah it's when she has the cream pile
over her face
which is a weird
[Laughter]
way
that was weird
i realized the sentence after now that's
just called a movie you're trying to say
mrs doubtfire may have used manscape i
think mr madoff may have used man well i
it is interesting if you think about
that movie that no one noticed robin
williams forearms
did you notice mrs doubtfire uh is a
gorilla no because she used landscape
landscape so when you're playing in the
sun make sure you're you're escaped
from pubes
to the bum
with a lawnmower manscaped 4.0
use our discount code crowder20 that's
20 off and free shipping at manscape.com
and i'm not kidding guys it's good it's
got a it's got a uh a light on it yeah
for when you want to shave in a tent
all right portable body tell them about
the taint guard dave there's a great
change guard i didn't know that that's
what it was called yeah it's actually uh
it's a guy who comes to your house
i don't think that fits in the box dave
he's got a big pass
that's a llama 4.5 yeah oh i'm sorry
yeah that's the thing i invented there's
one more man but yeah there is actually
a safety guard so which is very
important because me i get a i get real
shaky
uh still from not drinking and i don't
wanna i don't wanna uh what's the word
slice my sack
that's more of a phrase really yeah more
of a phrase yeah it's why i have a
tattooed on my arm don't slice your sack
yeah i told you you were going to regret
that people goes i don't it reminds me
people go is that a song lyric and i go
it's not it's just a way of life yeah so
go ahead again manscape.com 20 off plus
free shipping get yourself a shaver guys
you need it we're gross women are
beautiful honestly they just look better
than us yeah so let's try to let's try
to do something
what are you doing tim
[Laughter]
it's nice for us it's nice for you yeah
and honestly in the summer especially in
the texas heat
oh i take a shower i go outside for five
minutes
and i'm like
that was a waste of time is that
mine was that my haribo all right anyway
well look really quickly hey thanks for
supporting the sponsors who do have the
nicely shaven balls to sponsor this show
uh we do appreciate that and thanks to
all you guys like done we sell obviously
merch as well and we got a little bit of
grief yesterday because people were like
oh you're promoting merch yes
we weren't promoting merch to take
advantage of anything we were promoting
merchandise because we did a fight like
hell shirt a long time ago long time we
thought it was very very relevant today
for people to see what team you're on
like what the team if you want to pick
something else fine but not everybody
can subscribe not everybody can join mug
club not everybody's going to go out and
buy a manscape though you should try it
if you'd like that stuff but you can buy
a shirt you're going to buy shirts so
that's something that we do so if you
want to give us grief go for it we're
not out here this isn't a grift we've
been doing this for years you understand
our viewpoint for a decade of course and
complete transparency i didn't even have
to wear it i just spilled my morning
spaghetti all over the one that i were
to work and they gave me it to wear as
backup so that was just a coincidence
yeah absolutely lane you know how i love
my morning scaredy yeah that's weird
we have a good tradition that we have
going on
lane and i have a full italian uh so
that's pre-show richard
goodfellas jail meal
yeah it was great 27 million dollars in
merchandise sales just yesterday weird
yes crazy right yeah all crypto
yes
we got 27 million vietnamese dongs yeah
so it's like twenty and some money
that's like a shirt or two
so please send us your vietnamese dong
so we'll send you a shirt yeah i love
that it pisses off all the right people
yeah thanks for everybody for retweeting
our
advertisement tweet yeah yeah the promo
code in it yeah that's very nice yeah
i'm really really really disheartened by
the
magnet i mean no don't do that anymore
yeah no yeah okay guys you know yeah
please i don't want to make real i mean
we're really offended by all those yeah
you know you're just helping us put out
more content to kick your ass
it's a business
what do you want like we have to make
money yeah the next headline will be
funding the war through t-shirts
good lords
i mean don't go to
don't go to see us live or anything or
go to dave landed up no
you know
charlotte florida fort wayne indiana oh
no don't do it don't don't buy those
shirts terrible during the raid or heard
they found a fight like hell t-shirt
they did oh yeah they did that's he's a
powder fan so that's i mean i like
there's actually a piss off youtube
except it's just him pissing on you too
yeah he wanted the pleasure of doing it
himself
yeah that's what hey that's not a
russian at all
[Laughter]
i don't know how about that i'm sure
they employ a russian or two
there's also uh we're gonna talk about
this now speaking of which uh the fbi
raid update i know that they're changing
the word raid to uh i know shenanigans
or trick-or-treating yeah take a picture
of the definition online now before it
gets changed
do it for posterity
but uh comment uh if you like during
this please uh just what you think about
it what uh
what do you think about the fbi raid
what word do you think they should use
to describe it maybe
horseplay
shenanigans
tomfoolery is a good one
gerald
afternoon tea afternoon tea is a nice
one i like that yeah are you into uh
crumpets i am yes finger sandwiches are
always great oh like the salmon of
capistrano
that's from dumb and dumber all right so
the facts are surrounding the fbi's raid
of mar-a-lago continue to roll in but
according to the white house press
secretary biden knew nothing about the
um you know
the thing can you tell us anything more
was he watching the news was he
scrolling twitter did someone in his
staff flag it for him i can tell you
this he was not uh aware of of of uh
of
of the uh was it the mar-a-lago raid i
don't know what you guys are calling it
before it happened so i can
hmm
oh i'm sorry my headphones fell off i
shouldn't have buttered them
sorry
that's fine i know you like your butter
you know i like a crisco headphone i uh
did she have a titty cast
oh what she had like a yellow or a pink
i think it was a design of her clothing
oh was it thanks for taking that
literally yeah
so the law professors
have critical
yeah
the law the law professors have been
critical of the raid i got you covered
and it's pretext
clearly not a pedophile alan dershowitz
said it was totally unjustified
even one fbi agent would have been too
many
jonathan torley said
this is a historic raid the public needs
to know the reasons for the justice
department's decisions
william jacobson
said this is a provocation
they are trying to get a reaction that
allows a further crackdown the raid took
more than nine hours
during which
no one was allowed in agents searched
melania's wardrobe i don't blame them
better count the panties right bro broke
into trump's safe which was filled with
big macs
rifle through drawers the warrant
however only covered presidential
records and evidence of classified
information
the location of which was already known
so what was yours went down to
mar-a-lago and actually met with trump's
attorneys we are told it was back in
early june they believe and they met
with trump's attorneys i am told that
they were shown a room that had boxes of
documents that were there that days
after they left mar-a-lago they sent a
letter to trump's attorneys asking them
to further secure the room
that guy looks like liam neeson he just
hit him with a gun
i love this i love it it's like what are
you looking for here oh there's just you
know boxes of documents oh you mean the
ones that
you looked at you know three or four
weeks ago yeah
the ones that you told say hey put the
padlock on the door that we put the
padlock on the door for you that you
provided yeah that's right those
documents but we made a bigger deal now
yeah so you gotta have agents there for
nine hours to sort through this you
gotta understand gerald our poll numbers
are way lower than they were when we
came the first time i don't i have a
question if you wanted the republican
party to unite behind donald trump
more
than they already were potentially right
desantis is out there trump is out there
if trump decides not to run it's
probably desantis's race to leave if
trump runs he probably is the front
runner but did you want donald trump to
run again
because this just galvanized his support
people that don't like donald trump are
looking at this going what the hell
absolutely now i support this guy it's
like what demonetization does for mugs
yes yeah it's so stupid it rallies
everybody it really makes very little
sense but i i think that that we really
want to know the real reasons they were
in there and here
are seven plus reasons the feds really
rated mar-a-lago
[Music]
there's always one in the chamber every
single time
number seven
they wanted to stop him from putting
ketchup on a well done steak that's fair
that's fair a1 is there for a reason
it's true it's true and and it isn't
unless you're a terrible quarterback in
kansas city that's true
number six gerald
to seize the valentine's day card steve
bannon gave to him hugs and kisses
fraud daddy give me a five
to find his 4d chess board oh boom
lay in the brain can you hit me with a
four number four i mean it was the only
way they could afford a vacation in
florida in this economy that's actually
true gas is high that is extremely true
uh number three
to steal uh gold from his toilets to
back the us dollar
look if you're going to spend some time
in a room on a seat might as well be
gold yes of course well it's true
number two crawdaddy
they wanted the apprentice season 8 sex
tape of dennis rodman and joan rivers
nobody wants that nobody wants that tape
i can just see me after the show no
i wonder who has worse hair all right so
uh
he's in a wedding dress with a hole cut
in it yeah
so terrible
number one
to get their dvds of home alone 2 lost
in new york signed except the one guy
who brought the little rascals how dare
he
and of course the number one reason
lane
the plus one reason
oh sorry the plus one it's because
mar-a-lago is wonderful it's just the
greatest you can ask anyone and they'll
say this place is the greatest there you
go and that is seven plus one reasons
that we believe
the fbi rated marillacco
[Music]
ways always for getting the one in the
chamber so uh
do you think we do this maybe um
i think maybe we save it yeah for
tomorrow next segment so we're gonna
talk about some lonely single man either
tomorrow or uh next week it's a it's a
pretty good segment we don't want to
rush through it there's a lot of greater
no there's really good stuff in here
there's apparently a lot of very uh
lonely single men out there yes there i
think stephen would be interested in
talking about this yes yeah yes you know
it's really good stuff and fabulously
funny at the same time yeah yeah one of
our researchers even very lonely is
fantastic so he uh he wants to be able
to talk about lonely single men actually
just got me uh bass
uh squire
jazz bass jazz bass and i've been
playing it and uh i just kind of want i
was talking to casey about it yeah and
because i i just can't i can't finger a
guitar like i used to
mr guitar he's my neighbor
and
i um
it's dexterity yeah it's a perishable
skill dave
no it's just my figures are very
ladylike and long so they work better on
a bass believe it or not really yeah so
i uh
slap it like the seinfeld i'm trying to
i'm not a great sound i really is and
i'm a huge huge fan of les clay pools
like the king of the base slap and just
probably the greatest bassist ever i
heard a guy last weekend that was just
stellar really bright bass and then
switched to the oh did he really
oh my goodness i just love the sound
also i like that it's like it can be
upbeat jammy and also like
extraordinarily melancholy yes so maybe
i could play bass too while we talk
about lonely men and their suicides
[Laughter]
no maybe not we're just bringing a
lonely guy yeah hi i'm lonely guy
let's see if we can break you lonely man
i mean that's pretty interesting that
guy's probably lonely well because you
know his face
they tried to murder john bolton so i'm
kidding of course he's a very handsome
man for cnn allegedly
the iranians are just fun they're yeah
baggage is that funny in these encrypted
community encrypted communications
what is just going on in the middle east
that's
to pay up to a million dollars to carry
out perhaps another assassination so
that's what the concern is for the fbi
we've heard he's kidding
give me a million vietnamese dongs and
i'll take them out you can buy a burger
oh there's the thundercat and who's on
the left there
murphy brown
that's dated i know right a little bit
it's just a little bit there's three
fans that got it
no she's very old
she's very very oh
farmer john bacon 6.99
what are you guys trying to do here
199 are those good apples or the kind of
apples you throw at cars
[Laughter]
i love it by the way the tagline there
inflation slows to eight and a half
percent
in the stratosphere that's fine what
does that normally take seven years
exactly
at this pace we'll be like dead by the
time it gets back to normal thanks a
real win joseph r biden i want uh i want
people to know who are watching yeah son
you're not going to college
no i'm not even i'm just cashing i'm
cashing that in let's just say that now
ridiculous i hope you have a good set of
skills that can keep you employed
because i will not i don't care i hope
you're an art thief
it's not going to work why it's just who
cares do you know how good of an art
thief i am
no have you ever seen my gymnastic
skills when it comes to lasers can you
steal nfts oh yeah yeah oh yeah but are
you as hot as catherine zeta jones going
through the lasers not as hot but you'd
be surprised about my curves great ass
[Laughter]
no i i usually just trip immediately
yeah oh i set it off again margot
robbie's doorbell take me away boys
you again
they don't even arrest me because they
feel sad
you know who i bet has some moves who
cry daddy
i bet he's oh yeah i think so yeah
you're like you're tall
you got you're flexible i hear
as much as my
[Laughter]
it seems to be running away from you
yeah you're like oh yeah nothing like
chronic pain to make me want to steal a
painting
okay oh we just needed some hair spray
you know spray that in the air you know
we'll get the mona lisa
love it i don't even want them on at
least it's an ugly painting she's ugly
sorry she's a ugly person she is she's
got a [ __ ] face
she is a resting plain hair
no hairspray you can tell she didn't do
it yeah well no they didn't they didn't
even wash it back then it was an annual
bath where they got
dirt she's kind of a 1am at the bar hot
she's she's last call she's not 11 8
she's not 11 hot no
no she's not even 11 to talk to yeah
lane i i i have genuine concern for you
now why she's a 1am at the bar hot yeah
like you know it's almost two it was
almost closing time i mean she's still
there she's got that look that means
you've struck out for four hours yeah
consistently
yes
well
as lane and i would call that it's
called dating
i'm just glad you didn't say she's she's
not at 2 am at the bar last chance you
wait you wait for all your friends to
leave with attractive ones and then you
know aoc is like at 2 a.m
yeah we're talking yeah
we can get into that next 4 a.m you just
see a slide on over to that ditch pig
and you're like what's up girl
give her a fake name i rent a hotel
that's not more than 30 dollars
for the hour you know what i mean what
are you going to do with the rest of the
58 minutes
just saying that's not a bad dig a
shallow grave that's yeah that's not a
bad idea it's a terrible idea but
it's a great idea it's not i what do i
know i've ever i've been dated in 20
oh my god i haven't dated
i don't even care anymore i don't even
why didn't i talk about i'd be on one
day they'd be like so what's your
pronouns they'd be like i don't know i'm
leaving is that a pronoun you're paying
yeah here's the bill they say you should
have a date night every week with your
wife yeah do they say that what's tammy
doing who are they she's all right
is there a date in her future at some
point there's a little yeah a little
health stuff but yeah it's uh yeah
a picnic okay oh i want to go over to a
picnic can you call it a picnic please a
picnic there you go yeah i'm gonna have
yogi swipe some baskets appreciate that
and uh yeah we're gonna have boo-boo
i'm not even gonna go there boo-boo
can't do it
biscuits so you can bang your wife all
right so here's the
here's what we're going to talk about
right now though speaking of
dates and and just great things
netflix has released a lot of movies uh
that are pretty exciting i really
enjoyed the woodstock documentary 99 for
woodstock 99 because i actually had
tickets and at the time i was staying
with my aunt who was uh well my uncle
more or less forbade me to go
uh and boy after watching the
documentary am i glad i didn't
but there's another one out that i
really think we have to show because we
have crawdaddy here and it is the
trailer for where the crawdads sing
i'm going to get out of here
one way or the other oh no
oh what
what is what is happening
that's very good
my size 15 pumps stephen
[Laughter]
i think it looks good i'm going to watch
it what do you think you should i think
it looks good
i'm in i uh i hope you enjoyed it i did
i had to do it
i kept seeing the book at the uh like i
did a seat and run through i thought
something was afoot yeah yeah
i kept seeing it in the bookstore and
then once i realized it was a netflix
movie i was like oh i gotta do this like
it's gotta be
darren i didn't even know what that was
these guys kinda i had no idea i have no
idea what the movie's about i just like
the title i just don't wanna beat me up
no oh i know you could kill me but
that's why i knew he'd laugh i if i if i
thought he'd hurt me i wouldn't
but yes uh please comment comment
comment uh you can check us out
obviously every day uh 10 a.m eastern
ish right here on uh rumble uh the blaze
youtube uh if you want or whatever but i
would prefer
you know rumbly dumbledore there
whatever it is you do also catch me
august 26th 27th fort wayne indiana in
the first week of september you can
catch me at port charlotte florida a
little place called vasani they have
really good food i don't know if you
like italian food but if you don't
you're an idiot
so anyway
uh until tomorrow
piss off youtube
do
[Music]